MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
I'm Martin Omander and this is
the show Root Access, a show
on Google Developers Live
about startups.
And I'm joined today by Don
Dodge, startup advocate,
longtime investor.
So Don, we did a show a couple
of weeks ago about ownership
structure of your startup.
And we got a really interesting
question from
Anthony Kelly.
Thank you, Anthony, for
sending us a question.
He asked, what are some of the
Do's and Don'ts for attracting
investors and getting the
investors signed up?
And what are some of the
mistakes you've seen, and what
are some the right
ways of doing it?
DON DODGE: Well, you
need to choose
your investors carefully.
Sometimes companies are so
desperate for startup capital
that they'll take money
from anyone who comes
at almost any terms.
And you do what you have
to do, obviously.
But there are some things
you need to
do to protect yourself.
So when you take money from an
investor you need to be very
clear up front about what your
long term vision is.
So, is this going to be a 12
months and we sell it and flip
it kind of business, or is this
going to be a five year
kind of growth and
development and
building users and revenues?
And what kind of expectations
do they have?
So if you're clear with those
kinds of expectations up front
it makes it a lot easier
down the line.
So that's the first thing.
The second is to just think
about the ownership structure.
Is it common stock?
Is it a convertible note?
Is it preferred stock?
So those are fairly
generic terms.
What they mean is, common stock
is just regular stock
that employees get.
So employees, when they get
employee stock options,
they're getting common stock.
Investors, VC investors,
when they invest they
get preferred stock.
Preferred means that it has
preferences over the common
stockholders, typically in
doomsday scenarios, like when
you're shutting down the
company, or when the company
is being acquired, or those
sorts of things.
They might have preferences.
MARTIN OMANDER: So,
do they get paid
first if it shuts down?
DON DODGE: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: With the--
DON DODGE: So, preferred--
MARTIN OMANDER: --assets.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
Preferred means that they
get paid first.
They get preference.
And if there's any money left
over, it goes to the common
shareholders.
So that's fairly typical.
There are also convertible
notes, which have become
fairly popular recently.
Convertible notes means that
it's a loan that converts to
stock when you raise
your next round.
So it's an easy way
to raise money.
From a legal point of view,
it can be a one
page or two page document.
It's very inexpensive to do.
And it just lays out, here's
the money that
you're putting in.
It will convert to common stock
or preferred stock at
the next round, when you
raise your next round.
And typically it
has a discount.
So you might have a 20%
discount, where you put your
money in, and then some time
later, when you raise money
for a VC, if that valuation is,
let's say $5 million, and
you have a 20% discount,
then your money
goes in at $4 million.
Because that's the 20% discount
off the five.
So it typically has
a discount.
Or it might have cap, meaning
that you put your money in at
a cap of $4 million, and if this
takes off like a rocket
and you raise money at $10
million, your money goes in at
the cap of $4 million.
So, in essence you get 2 and
1/2 times your money right
away from the first round.
So it's those kinds of things
to look at with investors.
There are some other nuances
that are only an issue when
things go wrong.
But when they do go wrong,
you need to make
sure that your protected.
And that's where you have to
get a lawyer and really
understand what each of
those provisions say.
MARTIN OMANDER: So, you need
the lawyer up front.
Then, when you get investors--
just so that you have the
convertible note, or whatever,
set up correctly.
DON DODGE: Yes.
Lawyers do this every day.
So they know what provisions
to put in there.
Startup entrepreneurs
do it once in
their life, maybe twice.
So, it looks fairly simple, but
there can be some catches.
So it's always good to have
a lawyer who has done this
multiple times to set up the
initial documents for you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
In a similar vein, are
there Do's and Don'ts
about bringing founders--
co-founders on board?
DON DODGE: Yes, absolutely.
And it's a different set of
issues, equally important.
Maybe even more important.
MARTIN OMANDER: Uh huh.
DON DODGE: So, you need
to have they the same
understanding with
your founders--
your co-founders--
that you do with
your investors.
Meaning, here's what we're
going to try to do.
Here is how long it's going
to take to get there.
Here are the roles and
responsibilities that each of
us are going to have.
Here's what we're going to
contribute to the company.
Here's how we'll divide
up the founder shares.
If you have three founders,
it's not necessarily
33% for each one.
It could be that there's one
founder who, they are the
technical genius and the vision
of the company, and
they get 50% or 60%.
And the other two founders
split the remaining 40%.
But you need to be very clear
about that up front.
Second thing is, you need to
have employment agreements and
IP assignment rights.
Sounds kind of strange
to do that when
there's only two or three--
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Only two guys.
What's could happen?
DON DODGE: A lot could happen.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
DON DODGE: If you don't have
the IP assignments and
employment contracts, then they
are free to leave the
company at any time and take
their ideas with them.
So that's pretty dangerous
for an investor.
If an investor comes in and
says, OK, you've got an idea
and you've built it, and you
have three employees.
What happens if one of your
co-founders leaves?
And they can leave
with the idea and
start another company.
They're going to want employment
contracts, IP
assignment rights, and maybe
in some states non-compete
agreements.
Those don't work in California,
but there's
non-compete agreements that
say that if you leave the
company, you can't do exactly
the same thing at another
company for some
period of time.
So there's a variety of issues
that you need to face with
your co-founders very early on
that are setting expectations
and protecting the company in
case you leave, or protecting
the technology.
And again, a good startup lawyer
can take you through
this in an hour or so and just
make sure you're protected.
MARTIN OMANDER: So, lawyer early
on to help with that
piece as well.
DON DODGE: Yes.
You need a lawyer
for both pieces.
MARTIN OMANDER: Both pieces.
DON DODGE: To set up the
company, to set up the
agreements with your
co-founders, and also to set
up the financing documents
with early investors.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you very much, Don.
DON DODGE: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: I'm a
developer as well.
And when I do development,
I love to do it on
Google Cloud Platform.
It makes all management of your
application much easier.
You don't have to deal with
individual servers going up
and down and things like that.
Google takes care of all that.
We have a special offer for
you, Root Access viewers.
You can get a $2,000 credit
to start building your
application on the Google
Cloud Platform.
And you'll see the details
on screen.
And while you're trying that
out, in the meantime, I hope
to see at the next show.
And keep those comments
coming on YouTube.
We'll pick them up and deal with
them in future episodes.
Thank you.
Bye.